one other house of commons was
captivated last week when the Prime
Minister launched what's been seen as a
thinly veiled attack on the Mayor of
London Boris Johnson over his decision
to back the brexit camp and there's a
warning in the Sunday Times this morning
that David Cameron could face a
leadership challenge if the so-called
blue on blue attacks don't stop well
Chris Grayling the leader of the house
is one of the cabinet ministers company
to leave the EU and he joins me now from
sky center and a very good morning to
you Mr grayling morning noogie said in
any way ironic that the initial warning
when the campaign kind of began about
blue on blue attacks so-called came from
Downing Street they said they didn't
want to see any of that and yet the
Prime Minister seems to be the first to
carry one out well the important thing
is absolutely that point we're going to
go through four months of debate there
are different opinions in the party
everyone has got to go out of their way
to make sure that the debate within the
Conservative Party is a constructive one
an amicable one and one that doesn't
involve attacks on each other that's
really important so you do think the
Prime Minister made it personal then
well I mean I you can interpret the
words for Prime Minister use on Monday
at the number of different ways and I
don't want to come pick on that
particular example and say that's right
that's wrong I think going forward we've
got to make ish make sure that nobody
who is involved in the debate act in a
way that is hostile to any other member
of the party frankly that's true the
broader debate the country as a whole
wants to make its mind up on the basis
of hard facts on the basis of proper
information and evidence and none of us
go to win support by actually turning
this into a battle run the debate but
the Prime Minister I mean what was you
were sitting there what do you think
when you heard the Prime Minister he
seemed to be angered did he go over the
top well I'm he was setting out a point
of debates and you can interpret that
whichever way you want what I'm saying
is going forward we've got to make sure
that none of us do anything that is
easily interpreted as an attack on each
other we've got to be very careful to
make sure within the party and indeed
outside the party that this is a debate
that is measured constructive sensible
and of course from a conservative point
of view after the event we've really got
to make sure that when the result comes
in we come together we heal the party we
move on beyond the divisions and
discussions at the moment and we win in
2020
it isn't just that isn't it isn't just
what we all got to see in the House of
Commons then coming from deep we suppose
within the remain camp this suggestion
that the justice secretary michael gove
that he might face the the sack if your
side loses well look I have said I don't
believe at the moment the Prime Minister
is sitting in Downing Street plotting
sackings of ministers I mean it would
not be at all sensible when the
referendum is over for there to be a
purge of people on either side of the
argument if we are going to come
together if we're going to work
harmonious is a party and if above all
we're going to beat the Labour Party and
winning 2020 we've got to come together
well and there cannot be recriminations
at the end of this the Prime Minister's
done the right thing in giving us all
the freedom to debate on one side of the
argument or the other and I really
admire him for doing that all of us
involved in that debate must make sure
afterwards there are no recriminations
but don't you think they've been
surprised i mean there's the other
report they've been surprised with in
the conservative remain camp about that
the scale of the opposition to them from
within the party and from within the
cabinet well I'm not surprised there's a
lot of conservatives who want to leave
the European Union there's a lot of
people across the country you want to
leave the European Union I was out in
the Midlands yesterday in a number of
different places and getting a pretty
consistent message people coming up to
me saying we want to leave so I'm not
surprised there are strong feelings in
favor of leave in the Conservative Party
but what matters is for the next four
months we argue our case we set out our
views we try and win the arguments we
have the result and then we come
together because what we cannot do is
let Jeremy Corbyn anywhere near number
ten Downing Street but I mean just
nevertheless last thought on this kind
of issue of it that mean just how
important is the issue for you
personally if it turns out to be a
career-defining or indeed career
destroying moment you feel it's a price
worth paying well I'm not in this
because I'm trying to keep my place in
the cabinet or I'm trying to put in
danger my place in the cabinet I'm doing
this because I think it's the right
thing to do I genuinely believe Britain
would be better off outside the european
union that would be far more
opportunities for us in the world it
would open up new avenues for the United
Kingdom enable us to govern ourselves
again and that to me is more important
than my job it's more important than the
role I fell in cabinet and I think
that's true of all of us who are
campaigning to leave your opinion in
we're not thinking about our careers but
I
towards and I don't from moment think
that the Prime Minister is sitting in
Downing Street planning some kind of
Acts session it would be hardly the best
way of bringing the party together
afterwards and I don't from moment think
he's he's planning that at the moment
but passions are running high you've got
to admit that we hear that the Foreign
Secretary had some choice words let me
buddy that way to say about Savile cash
what passions often run high and debate
but they mustn't be lasting passions
we've got to make sure that we stay
friendly we stay constructive we come
together when the referendum is over and
what about this issue that I mean tell
me how it works with you this idea then
it's not an idea it's it's a diktat
coming from sir jeremy heywood head of
the civil service saying that ministers
like you shouldn't have access to the
civil servants if you're using the
information on the leave campaign well i
think the civil service machines and
everyone's could be very careful over
the next four months because government
has to continue we will have european
meetings we will have european documents
crossing our desks we will have to as
ministers take decisions about the right
way forward for the United Kingdom even
through the referendum period and so it
is really important that whatever
happens ministers can carry on running
their departments ministers can carry on
doing the right job for the United
Kingdom but of course nobody's actually
expecting when the Prime Minister is on
a different side of the argument for us
to be getting kind of detailed briefings
about what he's planning to do in the
days and weeks ahead yeah but if you
want some basic information about how
one of your proposals might be affected
whether we're in or out of the European
Union you want to use some of the
resources don't you of the of the civil
service the Prime Minister presumably
could tell Sir Jeremy to to change his
view on this couldn't Lee well I think
it's really actually important that on
both sides of the argument we are seen
not to use in appropriate amounts of
public money in appropriate amounts of
public time to put together information
that is going to be used as part of the
argument for the referendum now the
government has a formal position on this
and so of course the government and the
Prime Minister are going to argue that
formal position but the public will not
thank us if they see us wasting public
money as part of the debate process and
do you accept now that as the the Prime
Minister made very clear during the
course of law
last week that this referendum is the
final decision that there would be no
shilly-shallying afterwards and maybe
hoping that the EU makes up its mind if
I gone we're gone well I'm very clear if
we vote to leave we leave what then
follows is a discussion about our future
relationship with the European Union and
of course we will carry on trading with
them there a whole range of scare
stories around at the moment somehow we
know the world is going to change in a
way that's going to destroy businesses
destroy jobs the actual truth is that we
buy far more from the European Union
than they buy from us if anybody is
worried about the outcome at the moment
its continental businesses in France in
Germany and Spain and Italy who will not
want to see trading arrangements change
and that is why we'll carry on trading
we're carrying a habit of having the
opportunity to sell our products into
the European Union because they're not
going to put in danger the ability to
sell cars from Germany into Britain or
agricultural products cheese and wine
from france since britain that's not
going to happen but you won't accept
wouldn't you that the the leave side
have have a difficulty in painting for
the voting public what precisely the one
vision of britain post brexit would look
like when you've got everything from
george galloway socialist paradise to
nigel farage is red in tooth and claw
capitalist paradise what are people
going to make of it we're hearing that
the romaine campaign are going to be
asking those very questions about the 25
scenarios to consider from the leave
side well there's an awful lot of talk
from the romaine side about well you
want to be the Norwegian model you want
to be the Turkish model the Canadian
model I want us to be the United Kingdom
model we will negotiate our own
arrangements with the European Union we
will do so because we buy far more from
them than they buy from us and so
therefore they need us they need to
trade with us we will not accept
unlimited free movement in the way that
we have had up to now but nor are we
going to stop people coming in living
and working in other countries in the
right and proper way in a managed way
which we don't have at the moment but
these will be the subject of a detailed
negotiation when the time comes but when
it comes to the groups of people who are
campaigning yes of course there's a very
diverse group of people campaigning but
ultimately it will be a Conservative
government that leads us out the
European Union that leads us into a
relationship based on free trade or
brought a look around the world on new
relationships with emerging economies in
different parts of the world that can
create jobs and opportunities for people
and businesses here okay leader has
great talking to thank you very much
indeed Chris Grayling there